colombia está cerca de cumplir un mes de
manifestaciones antigubernamentales lo
que empezó como una protesta pacífica en
contra de la reforma tributaria ha
desencadenado enfrentamientos violentos
entre las fuerzas de seguridad y los
manifestantes el abuso policial es
reflejado en las cifras reportadas más
de 129 desapariciones y 27 casos de
violencia sexual situación que alarma a
la comunidad internacional hemos
recibido denuncias creíbles sobre 61
muertes ocurridas en colombia desde que
comenzaron las protestas hasta ahora
hemos confirmado que 24 de esas muertes
22 manifestantes o transeúntes y dos
policías tienen relación con las
manifestaciones sin embargo el gobierno
de iván duque no permitió la visita de
la comisión interamericana de derechos
humanos para verificar las denuncias
pero el paro nacional no da su brazo a
torcer nosotras estamos llamados a la
movilización
social y comunitaria del país como
pueblos originarios ya que con este
gobierno hemos tenido las mayores
violaciones de nuestros derechos derecho
de todos los colombianos se ha manoseado
la constitución porque en la
constitución están garantizados los
derechos para todos entonces eso es lo
que estamos manifestando en las calles
sin violencia las reuniones entre el
comité nacional de paro y el gobierno
están estancadas el gobierno ha
condicionado la negociación al
desbloqueo de las vías que traen consigo
desabastecimiento de alimentos y
medicinas mientras que los manifestantes
exigen medidas contra la brutalidad
policial